warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised what's up
everybody you're watching LED live candy
take it away
the show where we use the light of
Christ to expose the darkness found in
media and our culture today and before
we begin we'd just like to say thank you
so much to our subscribers and if you're
watching right now and you and you
haven't subscribed yet go ahead and
click that subscribe button and the
notification bell so you can join the
conversation when we put out in new
videos today we're excited we have a
special guest
take it away Michael find out on this
episode of LED live thanks for coming on
the show yeah thank you thank you it's a
pleasure to be here um I basically
wanted to talk about transformed about
the transformation that God wants to do
in each one of us and as I was putting
together this program about
transgenderism I started to realize just
the impact of what that had for me as
well being born the first thought that I
had as I became conscious about between
the ages of 3 & 4 was that I'm a girl
trapped in a boy's body I didn't know
what any other truth was other than the
fact that I knew that I did not match
what was in my physical body and that I
wanted to be like my sisters I didn't
know how it happened I didn't know where
it all began but just a few years ago as
I started to put this program together
it started to answer some of the
questions that I had in my own existence
and so I want to kind of talk about that
today if we can yeah all right you know
better than coming from personal
experience so I mean we're excited to
have you on here because we kind of want
to really understand this topic we've
explored it a little bit but
to shed some light on this great
absolutely so as I present feel free to
ask any questions that you might have
all right so this is something that I
found really surprising that National
Geographic actually dedicated an entire
issue to the transgender movement about
a year and a half ago
and underneath here you can see just a
few of the different identities or
pronouns that you can go by and to call
yourself
there's non-binary a gender androgynous
cisgender and the list just goes on
there's now over a hundred different
ways that you can identify and you can
imagine the confusion that's in the
world now they actually have laws that
are supporting that you have to use the
correct pronoun for the type of person
that you're working with otherwise
that's considered hate speech so you can
imagine the memorization that you would
have to do to make sure that you've got
somebody's pronoun correct I want to
share with you a video clip talking
about a television show called our
America and they actually dedicated
their program to the transgender issue
as well take a look the way I work out
is I like to go go go go party as fast
and strong this is 32 year old Tom and a
lot of the guys can't keep it on the
surface Thanh is strong and confident
but for years Thanh has struggled with a
conflicted sense of self and a secret
come on chronicles Thanh was born Tanya
a woman
it's one of the most basic ways of
identifying ourselves male or female
you're either one or the other but for
millions of people their physical gender
doesn't line up with their inner sense
of self they are transgender
imagine your brain in the opposite
genders body how would you feel what
would you do I was just born in the
wrong body
this is a story of transformation of
different people across America in
different stages of life I'm about to
meet these people and witness their
journey of change from the sex they were
born to the one they feel they really
are well so was that interesting that
you saw the person working out that they
called Thanh and all of a sudden you
realize that it's Tanya that time wasn't
that surprising it definitely was I got
a question on I want to know he just
said it was like a mental thing like my
mind is different than my body what why
do you think it is that this is treated
differently than any other mental like
if somebody says I'm fat and you say no
you're not Li you know you try to change
their mind or show them the truth or
somebody that says like they're
depressed you try to help them when it
comes to this you can't it's almost like
illegal in some cases it is to tell them
no you really are a boy let's let's talk
this out why do you think there's such a
difference than the way it's handled I
think part of it is sincere I think it's
a genuine issue and your question is you
know why is it not treated as a mental
illness and that's because of
legislation and also an agenda that's
being pushed and promoted on us now I
would have bought into that whole idea
even as a little child that was like six
or seven years old they now have laws in
the United States where if you're a
little child and you come forward and
you say I'm a girl trapped in a boy's
body the law can actually intercede
against the will of the parents and
start giving that child on hormone
blockers so that that child can
eventually have the sex change that they
want is there an age limit to them I'm
not sure of any age limit just whatever
whenever that child reveals to a teacher
or to you know some professional that
reports it but if I was that little kid
if I was alive and a little kid during
this day and age at six years old I
would have been standing first in line
absolutely there was no way that I
thought that my body and my mind could
become one on that I prayed I asked God
to change me that he would change me
into a little girl and that I would be
like my sisters and I knew that I wasn't
like the boys in the neighborhood but I
knew I wasn't like my sisters either so
I was trapped in this kind of gender
purgatory if you would knowing that I
was different but yet I didn't even know
who I was is that what they would call
agender or non-binary not fitting either
way um not necessarily it's called
gender dysphoria is the clinical term
for it and I think that that's even
being written out because that's
considered a mental illness or a mental
disorder yeah let me go on I what I want
to share with you now is this is the
same person this is Jamie
and Jamie's holding a box of the
hormones that she's gonna take and this
is the transformation that you're gonna
see from from Jamie as a female to Jamie
as this male looking person take a look
and just watch just what the hormones
alone do without surgery
[Music]
the ending title said girls to men mmm
little play on boys the minute yeah yeah
more than that you know woman why not
woman to men or why not girls to boys
why is it girls to men I don't know is
just something that popped out at me
what is it with that sure it's
interesting because now with the focus
being so hyper focused on gender and
identity that's something that I think
that they definitely would be concerned
about and I bet that they were even
intentional about that you know going
from a girl to a man meaning this
transition you know instead of from girl
to a woman you know a girl tremendous
ting I never even thought of that but
when you look at the picture of of Jamie
there isn't that shocking and generally
what I ask people is I say if you were
just looking at this individual and that
person came into your church would you
let them date your daughter I believe
that the LGBT issue is nothing compared
to what transgenderism is going to do to
the church because if you can't tell the
difference between men and women then
you're not going to be able to know the
difference between husbands wives
mothers fathers sisters or brothers
right and now this question gets even
larger because it's not it's not like
homosexuality where it's like this is an
a self-identifying man that wants to
date a woman like what do we do with
that well let me make it even more
confusing for you in the state of
Tennessee a few years ago it was
unlawful to have your birth certificate
changed to your to your transgender so
meaning that if I was born biologically
a male I couldn't have my birth
certificate change however there was a
couple a lesbian couple that decided
that both of them were trans and so one
of them was born in Florida and in the
state of Florida it was legal to have
the birth certificate change so she now
became a he and because in the state of
Tennessee gay marriage was not
acceptable but because she had a male
birth certificate from Florida she was
able to marry her lesbian partner on
legally in the state of Tennessee
yes it just gets even more and more
confusing and we know that the devil is
the author of confusion and I think that
you'll be even more confused as we go
forward well so this couple that married
though they they both identified as men
correct even though neither of them had
had surgeries on they both had started
on the hormones but their bodies were
physically female so I want to move on
to the next slide defense of detachment
and and gender dysphoria that was the
term that we were talking about a little
bit earlier I talked about how when I
came to Christ at 40 years old I had
these questions I wanted to know why at
my earliest thoughts that I was a girl
and not a boy or a girl trapped in a
boy's body and one of the things that
God helped me to see was that there was
a defensive detachment that occurred
between my father and I my dad was in
the Navy so he's gone a lot but then
when my dad was home he was raging a
hot-headed Italian and he was abusive so
at that time when little boys start to
make this this attachment to their
same-sex parent what happens is they
have to leave the comfort of the mom and
they they go to the dad so in a good
home and in a healthy home you know dads
take the kid and throws them in the air
and wears baseball caps and so the
little boy starts to imitate that you
know if they realize that dads are
exciting and dangerous and so they want
to imitate masculinity what happens is
you have this this basically like wet
cement it has no identity no shape but
what happens is as a boy transitioned
from the mother to the father then
masculinity starts to take shape with
this wet cement and all of that is
healthy gender stamping and that's why
eventually boys grow up and they only
want to play with boys because you know
girls are grows all of that is healthy
gender stamping so that this masculinity
hardens this cement and so for me during
that time when I was needing a male role
model which should have been my father
he either wasn't there or he was abusive
so in my mind in my defense I detached
from my father I wanted nothing to do
with that identity and so I reverted
back to my mother because she was the
only other option
I didn't make that decision it was
something that was before I was even
conscious but all of a sudden at the age
of four or five I realized whoa
something's going on here
I had three sisters and I wasn't like
them but it wasn't like the boys in in
you know in my neighborhood either so
then when school started the sex it was
a mystery to me was actually my own and
so I got more rejection from the boys
that called me queer little girl
because they were picking up on my
mannerisms because my wet cement was
being formed in the feminine because I
was patterning after my mother and again
I didn't know how to fix it I thought
the problem was in my mind and that my
body had to change and that it was my
mind that was fixed and couldn't change
so you can see that this happened even
at a time where I thought that okay
wouldn't be convincing to think that I
was born this way you know if it was my
first thought then that must have
happened even in vitro so you you really
came from the mindset of you were born
in the wrong body absolutely no doubt in
my mind but again it was from a
four-year-old's perspective you know if
that's all you've ever known then it's
easy to understand or to buy into the
idea that oh I must have been born this
way so you think that would have changed
if your father was more present in your
life I you know even if he was more
present in my life I think I probably
still would have rejected him because he
was he was um aggressive and abusive so
I would have had that even more around
so I don't know if that would have made
a difference or not but I do remember
being 10 years old when my father took
us to the lake to announce that he was
divorcing my mom and I remember sitting
in the car my sisters were in the
backseat and my dad making this
announcement that he and my mom were
going to divorce and I remember thinking
to myself good you're out of here to me
that was an affirmation that I had
defensively detached from my father
because my sisters were in the back seat
screaming and crying dad don't go so
that helps me realize that there was a
defensive detachment that had taken
place years before and that helped me to
to actually understand more of what was
going on I struggled with transgender
ideation until I was 20 years old I
remember um every emasculation and I was
a little kid and I grew two inches out
of high school and I'm only five five
now so you can imagine it was really
tough for me my mother put me in school
when I was five years old so you know I
was still way behind the kid
on average for development and
coordination and I remember that I went
to a school in Detroit Michigan Dearborn
Michigan and they had such a wealthy
school system that they actually had a
built in swimming pool inside the
schools so every winter time in the
schools the boys would have the pool for
a week and then the girls would have the
pool for week
so more emasculation would only drive
the desire to be feminized because what
the message that I got was that I was
inadequate as a boy I didn't measure up
as a guy and so the only option for me
is that I should be a female the desire
was to fit in the desire was to be
included and to be accepted and so if
I'm not included or accepted as I am
then that gave me the drive that oh I
should change I even thought to myself
that if I was a female then maybe men
would love me maybe I would receive
masculine love which was really the
baseline desire of what I had so when
the boys had the pool for the week I
don't understand this and it's going to
shock you I'm sure but the boy swam
naked 32 boys in eighth and ninth grade
for that whole weeks when they get and
again it gets this I know it gets worse
public school yeah so the boys would
pair up for situps and you'd have to
hold the you know the guys ankle while
he's doing his situps and we did jumping
jacks on the side of the pool Wow
absolutely thank you yeah Michigan and
this is born Michigan I even asked my my
I even asked my stepfather's brother and
he was you know several years older than
me and I asked Mike you know did you
swim naked you know when you when the
guys had the pool and he said yeah which
is the common thing nobody batted an eye
but what that did is as I compared
myself to the other guys you know I
still hadn't hit puberty and and some of
the guys had beards so it was just a
constant reminder that I just didn't
measure up as a guy so my fantasies
about becoming a woman were even
probably the most at that time because I
would fantasize that if I was a girl
then everything would be okay and I
wouldn't have to compete
I wouldn't have to measure up and I
wouldn't have to worry about whether I
fit in or not but at 20 years old when I
couldn't get my religion and my
sexuality to come together and I went
into the gay culture for the first time
at 20 years old I realized that
masculinity was more valuable than
femininity what I wanted was male
affirmation so even in that culture if I
if I butch it up a little bit more and
if I worked out in the gym then I found
that I got all the attention from men
that I wanted and I never struggled with
the transgender issue again it just went
away and so for me even at 20 years old
even before that in church culture I got
the message from God that I was
unacceptable the way I was and if I had
attractions for the same sex then the
only way that my attractions would be
acceptable to God is that my body should
become feminized hmm so again even in my
mind I remember thinking to myself this
would be the only answer I hope that
what that does is that that helps you to
see from from the transgenders
perspective that this isn't a show this
isn't something that they're just trying
to promote or put out there I mean
there's a genuine issue that's really
driving a lot of this right if they had
a choice they would probably really wish
that it was a normal you know
desire that they have but they have this
you know unnatural desire that they're
trying to grapple with and figure out
and I mean that's that's why we wanted
to open up this conversation when I was
like what do we do with this my my right
that's the question I had that you were
talking a lot about how you felt on the
inside and your thoughts and things like
that I was learning if there were any
outward expressions of those thoughts
and just things that we can pick up on
in small children who are craving this
masculine what was the word you used
affirmation affirmation right right
right so it's good it's a really good
question because a lot of times the
question that I'll get is you know how
do I help a child that I see is
obviously effeminate like an effeminate
little boy and and most people
especially Christians they they have
this narrow viewpoint that they think
that oh because my child is feminine
that that means that they're gay and and
that's a big misnomer because just
because somebody is effeminate doesn't
mean that they're homosexual because
children aren't even sexualized until
puberty unless they've been exposed to
abuse but I remember that that the
thoughts inside my head is that my dad
made an honest effort to try to make me
more masculine and so he he was a cop so
he would take me out shooting guns well
that was even more aggressive behavior
which all he drove me further away from
wanting to be a man and then he would
take me to where they would attack train
guard dogs you know German Shepherds for
guard duty I just wanted to pet the dog
and so again it was just like every time
my dad made these earnest efforts you
know it only reinforced the fact that
I'll never cut it I'll never be like
them I hate that kind of stuff but what
it did is it drove me back into you know
playing dolls and dress-up with my
sisters and my mom so imagine the power
right and we think that it has to be
something earth-shattering but what I
didn't do is I didn't connect with my
same-sex parent and so what I needed is
I needed to know that being masculine
was acceptable attainable and desirable
and so even in my mind and you said
something earlier Scotty about um that
that in my mind I wanted to cut it as a
boy I really didn't I wanted to be a
girl and even if it was an option for me
I would have preferred to be a girl
because of the thoughts inside my mind
so and again we're talking about a child
that doesn't even have reasoning
capabilities
right and so even if that was my desire
imagine the power of my father would
have just gotten on the ground with me
and colored in my coloring book what I
needed to know is that I wasn't away
from masculinity and that it could be
something that I could relate to and so
if my dad would have just done that
simple little thing or even taken bath
time or you know and and to use that
time to affirm me and to spend time with
me you know bedtime you know having
devotions all of that spending time with
the same-sex parent would have helped me
to acclimate and to see oh it's not that
distant it's not that far away maybe
this is something that would be
desirable so you know when talking to
people just because somebody is
effeminate as a boy doesn't mean that
they're gay it just means that they
either didn't have an example of
masculinity or they didn't bond with
that same-sex parents it sounds like
you're you're not just saying
masculinity you're saying that the child
needs to see in the masculine parent a
form of gentleness and kindness that
kind of helps make that bridge in
transition absolutely so that they can
say okay well I can also get this over
here it's not so much about either/or
it's and it's both you know they need to
know that they can get you know that
comfort from the male parent as well as
seeing things that are dangerous and and
fun and exciting as well keep that's a
really great point and I had never
really put it together that well but
that's is it because I went to my mom
for comfort safety and security from my
dad
I just got aggression and hostility
which was undesirable so I needed to
know that my father was affectionate and
loving and kind also did your dad ever
hug you yeah my dad was very
demonstrative with his affection we were
Italian so my father kissed me up until
the time that he passed away when I was
like 47 so so that wasn't an issue that
we struggled with but I definitely got
the opinion that masculinity was
overbearing aggressive and unavailable
now it seems like what wasn't missing in
the home was a well-rounded view of what
mother is and then what father or the
woman is or what a man is I think that's
also missing as a conversation in family
or also in church because I mean I
didn't grow up with any of gender
dysphoria anything like that but I do
remember being a little girl and being
frustrated being a girl because of what
I thought was my future mom as a woman I
thought oh you know I have to be super
soft and I have to be in the kitchen all
the time and yes I wanted to have kids
but it was kind of put in front of me as
like a burden because of what I was
seeing not as just not necessarily that
woman were you know openly telling me
that kids are burden or whatever but
just hearing certain conversations and
the moms always complaining and saying
they're so frustrated with their kids
and I'm like man this really what I have
to expect later on in life and but
that's completely false women can be
strong women can be independent and also
be submissive in a relationship with the
husband and all these things so
regardless of whether a child is dealing
with gender dysphoria or not I just
think having a complete view of what it
means to be a man and what it means to
be a woman both the gentle and
aggressive depending on when it's
necessary is very important for any
young child right need to you need both
absolutely absolutely every little boy
needs a mother and a father just like
every little girl needs a mother and a
father as well and it's interesting
because in homes where they don't have
fathers and they have statistics now
that say that there are more single
mothers raising families and dual
parents and they say that that statistic
can never go back so now you have homes
where little boys don't have a hero to
look up to or where an example of what
masculinity is and then you also don't
have girls to have a father that will
bounce her on his knee and tell her that
she's a princess and that he'll protect
her so you have boys and girls that are
growing up without this father image
without the safety and security and and
and that's kind of like something that
you can sense in the air even though I
was thrilled that my dad was gone as a
single mother my mom was raising us for
kids I knew that there was a certain
level of insecurity in the home because
dad wasn't there to protect us even
though I didn't want him there so even
even if you don't even know
and the difference and if even if a
child was raised without a father in the
home there is I think generally that
kind of feeling there's a woman that was
raised by a lesbian couple and she loved
her parents she was raised in a good
home but she even said she was always
envious of the little girls that would
have their fathers when they would come
to school for different programs and
even she became sexually active at an
early age she was never homosexual but
she was sexually active at an early age
because she felt that she wanted the
love from men more and it wasn't until
she was actually married and had
children of her own that she looked at
her children and she realized that she
had been denied that that opportunity to
have a father figure in her life and and
she realized the emptiness of what that
cost for her and I don't want to get too
too off of the topic and want to get
back on it because that that's an
amazing point because I can relate to
that
coming from a single-parent household
okay and just what my mom did to try to
fill that gap of the father being absent
and that's where the church family came
in and that's why it's so important your
church family because I was in
pathfinders and you know I got to to
view well you got around men right so I
was able to go to pathfinders I was
around men in the church and seeing how
they interacted with other women and
also children and I mean I didn't have
to go to the extent of them bouncing me
on underneath right but just seeing that
having that in my view and not just any
man but a spiritual man was very
important so she definitely made sure
that I got that beautiful beautiful
perfect example so I want to show you
the picture this is me smack dab in the
middle of six girls three of them are my
aunt's and three of them are my sisters
and this is who I played with it's
almost like you know the rejection of my
father's masculinity being rejected by
the boys in school and then being
surrounded by nothing but girls I had no
male cousins or uncles or anything that
I played with this is who I grew up with
and I was perfectly fine with that but I
also believe that this had a lot to do
with some of that that's shaping that I
was growing
I think this is interesting I was just
looking at one of the Oscar photographs
or whatever and came across this and I
heard this dialogue between the the the
news people and this film clip as they
showed this man in this dress this gown
and him and his male partner were there
as well and it's interesting to see how
the media is shifting now it's a very
heterosexual newscaster that was male
and a female and they were talking about
the diversity and how how wonderful it
is to celebrate the the transitioning of
people being open to gender and identity
so we definitely know the through the
media that there is an agenda that's
going on talking about non-binary this
is the definition of non-binary is
somebody who is not determined by
masculinity or femininity so maybe on
Tuesday feels like dressing as a woman
and then on Thursday feels like dressing
as a man and the idea is that he floats
through the gender binary so he's not
defined by either one I mean wouldn't it
be interesting if you went to work and
all of a sudden your boss was like you
know it's a it's a woman or maybe one
day it's a man and it's like different
like that would just be an interesting
or what if this is your parent yeah your
you sometimes you got a dad sometimes
you got a mom I say is he is this
personality really changing with each
persona you know what if it was your
spouse Oh cuz we're gonna talk about
that a little bit later too this is
actually the gentleman that won the
Eurovision song of the year in the
European Union every year they have a
competition between the countries and
this is the person that actually won
that year his name is Conchita Wurst I
lived in gay culture for 20 years I saw
men that looked just like this only it
was in a bar you know now to see that
the public expression and acceptance of
people like this it was even shocking to
someone like me I also want to share
with you this is the gentleman that's in
charge of the sex education for the
European Union and this is something
that they were promoting it hadn't
actually been approved but this is what
was before them to introduce a sex
education to all of the ten countries of
Europe from zero to four years old they
want to teach children not just how to
masturbate but how to enjoy it from four
to six years old they want to teach them
homosexual practice six to nine years
old they want to teach
reception and they haven't even gone
through puberty but by the time they're
nine years old they want to teach the
gender orientation where they split up
the boys and the girls and they can
crossdress and from 12 to 15 year old
they want to teach them how to practice
BDSM which is sadomasochism so the idea
is now that you've taught them how to
have sex now you could teach them how to
abuse each other sexually you know what
I found interesting about this is
nowhere in here is the typical mindset
of a male and a female and a normal you
must be married and six inside of the
marriage context is the best way to go I
mean this isn't the negative effects of
these things this is like completely
outside of what it means to be in a
family right because again the issue is
to destroy the family to destroy the
idea of that and destroy in these and
these children's mind what normal and
healthy sexual behavior is and so wait
BDSM is like sadomasochism like
masochistic statistic behavior I like
dominant versus submissive so his early
when you're looking at this does the
lesson is the legislation stating that
this has taught exclusively at the
exclusion of the other or is it both are
taught together with an emphasis on one
or the other
do you know I I don't know I don't have
privy to that kind of information but I
think it bears saying that you know when
you teach a child or expose them to
sexual things I never even thought about
sex until puberty and I was never
molested but children that have been
molested it awakens in then this this
awareness of sexuality or sensuality
even so again this is nothing nothing
less in my opinion than child abuse
because when you're exposing young
children to these kind of behaviors and
experimentation you're actually
educating them and in
indoctrinating them so when I was
growing up if a father were to sit down
his four-year-old kid with a pornography
magazine when you get arrested for
something like that and homosexual
practice at four and six years old
so is that saying that you can practice
sex with a kid that young so I really
want to kind of hold off on this
discussion because we're gonna get to
that we're gonna talk about what is that
like and what is the agenda and where
did it start so can we just move on for
a minute because I so now this isn't
just limited to to what's going on in
Europe this is also going on in
Australia they talk about the rainbow
politics allowing male students to wear
female uniforms boys can now wear skirts
to school in Puerto Rico and Las Vegas
schools are considering teaching their
kindergarteners about masturbation and
homosexuality so this is not just
isolated to one area this is going on
around the world the human beings are
created male and female but the current
transgender ideology goes way beyond
that
they're telling us that you can be both
genders you can be no gender you can be
a gender that you make up for yourself
and we are all supposed to just accept
and affirm it this is from a Christian
perspective it's from the Family
Research Council but this is exactly the
agenda that's being promoted want to
talk about the fact that we know that
the sooner that you can educate children
the sooner you can change the culture
and so this is a book that was on Amazon
and I was just looking at Amazon and I
found this book about Jacob and his new
dress and this is all geared towards
preschoolers here's another book that I
found talking about the princess boy and
it talks about the princess boy has a
cool brother and his brother dances with
my princess boy the princess boy loves
his brother and here's the princess boy
and his brother the transgender child it
goes on it says the princess boy loves
his dad and his dad loves to take him by
the hand and watch him twirl my princess
boys smiles and hugs his dad and in the
last picture that I have here is my
princess boy has playdates with boys and
girls he likes to climb trees and his
princess boy tier a crown
he plays dress-up he likes to change
clothes a lot he wears a green ballet
leotard and dances with his friends all
of this is targeted towards changing the
ad
toons of young people because the sooner
you can change their their minds about
the transgender issue the more
normalized you're making these behaviors
that's one of the reasons why we wanted
to start this conversation in the first
place is I believe that families need to
start having these conversations with
their kids like this is what's coming
down the pipe and you know if your kids
are gonna be exposed to other kids in
the world this is what other kids are
learning these are school systems that
you may not be widely available in the
u.s. at this point but it will be it's
coming so it's interesting
scottie because these conversations
shouldn't even just be limited to the
home they need to be done in church and
this is what's going to happen if if you
stop and think about it even the
influence that a parent has versus when
they start going to school and then
they're influenced by the teachers and
the principals and their other
classmates your voice is going to become
very very small and considered very
judgmental this is a video talking about
how the prejudice against LGBT issues in
the Caribbean and talking about how to
change those attitudes and the media is
targeted to definitely change our
attitudes about transgenderism take a
look famous sports icons on a planet
such as Hussein Boat who is sponsored by
urging if this man can Electrify the
planet in a space of nine seconds and
send his home country Jamaica into a
frenzy when he wins race many are aware
that his native island is not tolerant
of the LGBTI agenda at all so to break
them down if you just cleverly adorn
that icon in a dress it will slowly
break down any resistance
only those who understand advertising
and media are fully aware of how it
works yes read every Bernays propaganda
book published in 1928 and he advised
corporations to use famous icons to
promote an agenda even if they are not
fully aware of what they are doing so
now this is something that little light
studios definitely has a grip on and one
of the things that I found amazing is
Madonna actually did an interview with
Rolling Stone magazine back in the in
the 80s and basically the interview went
like this they said why do you put so
many references to homosexuality in your
music videos and her response was you
know at first many people would be
disgusted she said but as they see it
over and over again eventually they'll
get turned on by it or they'll
eventually just get used to it and she
understands the movement of the media
and I believe that this is the the same
agenda that's being promoted as well did
you know that the whole idea about the
LGBT acceptance happened ten years ago
it started 10 years ago and the whole
idea was to use media to change the
culture and so now we see the
culmination of what that's done around
the world it's why when they made what's
that movie with it the cowboy
Brokeback Mountain okay it's the
number-one reason why they chose to make
a middle America cowboy you know story
and put him in a homosexual light was to
literally hit at the heart of America
and change the mindset way back when ten
10 15 years ago if there's a great book
called after the ball and it basically
talks about the whole gay movement and
how it's been initiated many decades ago
it's interesting because back when I was
young there was a program called I think
was called making love and it was about
a man that was a doctor and his wife and
how they had this wonderful life the
beautiful people or whatever and all of
a sudden he ended up in a homosexual
relationship and when that movie was
released
I remember being 18 19 years old and
shocked by it but of course definitely I
made sure I watched it but the media
frenzy about the unacceptance and and
that the America wasn't ready for
something like this they had to actually
put it back in the class
they had to let it rest and let people
get out of it but what they would do is
they would stick their feet in the water
every now and then they would test the
test to see what the culture was
accepting or not and so what they did is
basically like the frog in the pot you
know instead of just putting him in
boiling water they just turned up the
heat slowly and eventually now we have
so much acceptance to that but it
definitely was an agenda yeah so I want
to tell you about this family they're a
family with a secret now these are
actually the mother and father of these
two little boys they biologically gave
birth to these children but would it
surprise you to know that Bianca the
mother used to be a little boy named
Jason and that Nick the father actually
was a little girl named Nicole so really
what happened is they were to gender
individuals to transgender individuals
and they both went off of their hormones
and so the mother actually impregnated
the father and they gave birth to these
two children completely toys didn't this
is what's coming into this is what's
coming into the world now I mean you
know if if what your ideas of what a
male or a female come from the
imprinting of the father like you talked
about in the very beginning yeah what
does this do when you're a little boy
and you're raised now with this really
opposite ended view I wouldn't even
begin to know and I'm sure that they
haven't even been able to do studies
about that they haven't even done
studies about the harmful effects of
putting little children on hormone
blockers they don't even know the the
the the risk that's involved they do
know that the hormone blockers whenever
you like if you give a boy female
hormones imagine the firestorm that
you're creating on the inside of this
body because that little boy is
releasing male hormones and now you
injected these female hormones and so
they they're fighting not only are their
emotional issues that can that can come
because of it and that child is gonna
have to stay on these hormones for the
rest of its life
there's just no going back and so they
found that not only shortens their life
expectancy it also increases their rates
of cancer and they actually have to take
ant anti-cancer causing drugs to
actually keep the cancers from
developing sooner in their bodies so
there's a whole lot of side effects just
from the medications alone but you know
without the emotional issues but the
question that I really
a scan that I present to most people is
if this family came to your church would
they be accepted there you know would
they see the shocked looks on our faces
would they would they be able to find
out who Jesus was if they came into your
church and I think that it really
challenges the way that we look at
people and they look at other society
because a lot of times you know we're
surrounded in church by people who look
like us and but I believe that Jesus
died for them just as much as he died
for somebody like me and being an ex
homosexual that came into Church culture
with a boyfriend and a sexual addiction
I felt like this family as I went into
that church culture and and I hid I was
afraid that if somebody knew who I
really was that that the church you know
would take action and kick me out or
talk about me so I I think that it's a
real real challenge to Christianity
because not only do we have to recognize
the issue and we need to be educated and
and that's what this is all about but
not only to be educated about what's out
there in the world because you're not
going to change this this is happening
there's no going back but how is it that
we can teach people how to love to be
loving and to show the the power of
Jesus Christ to people that either we
don't understand or maybe even find
disgusting because that these people
deserve that same love the core they're
looking for acceptance whether it is
from their same gender or office of
gender or a confusion of the of the two
everybody wants to be accepted and we
have to figure out how not to alienate
them in a way that pushes them away from
from from God because I honestly believe
that if they if they were around in this
way in Christ day they would have been
drawn to him and we need to have that
same they need to be you know drawn into
our churches because it is a loving
environment we have examples of that how
about the woman caught in adultery
you know this Mary was it was shocked
that Jesus didn't condemn her but but he
told her not to do this anymore you know
it's interesting because the LGBT gay
affirming group that are within our
church now in Christianity they're
basically promoting that that that is
hate speech when Jesus told her to go
and sin no more it's not interesting
that the words of Jesus would actually
be considered hate speech and that's the
movement also that we're seeing within
Christianity is that there's
words and certain phrases that we have
to stop saying because according to
these other groups that that's
considered hate speech but the challenge
really I believe is is that we have to
stand for the truth of God but the truth
of God has to be loved and I think that
Christians have a huge responsibility in
shaping some of that because Christians
have been hateful in the name of Christ
for many years um they did a study
actually in Chicago and they they went
around with a microphone and they
basically just asked people on the
street they said what comes to your mind
when I say Jesus Christ and they put the
microphone in front of them they go oh
Jesus was fair he was loving he was kind
all of the adverbs that you know you
would expect to to find you know for
Jesus but then they said well what comes
to your mind when I say the name
Christian you know and then these people
were not Christian at all and they said
haters judgers unfair unkind I mean they
gave all these attributes that were
absolutely the opposite of who Jesus was
and I believe that we as Christians are
responsible and have to take
responsibility for that but we have to
also hold on to the truth we don't throw
out the truth to be more loving the
truth in itself is love we have to offer
somebody we have to offer the world
something better than what they're
getting in the world and I believe that
instead of focusing on behavior
modification because that's what the
world offers and and they're saying that
that's hate in itself what we're
offering is divine intervention a divine
relationship with Jesus Christ and you
can't get that in the world so we're
trying to separate I believe out the
differences is that now this isn't
reparative therapy and conversion
therapy and our job isn't to make gay
people straight our job is to show
people who Jesus Christ is we
demonstrate that how we live but then
also as people study they get introduced
to a relationship with Jesus Christ as
well but I think that that's the real
struggle within Christianity now is
because we have a label of being haters
because that's how we've been for the
last hundred years or more so I want to
play for you this clip and I want to get
some feedback guys with to how this this
hits you so let me just play the quick
way
[Music]
the single most common question I get
asked is are you a boy or are you a girl
the simple answer is no but then that
the response after that is usually a
very confused what so here is the
explanation
I am non-binary and that means identify
as something other than male or female
our society and history has led us to
believe over thousands of years that
there are only people who are male and
people who are female but that is
because past society is based gender on
physical sex let me see what it is nurse
yes what a strapping young lad it's
outdated the truth is the genders in the
brain and physical sex is a completely
separate and different thing that is
private to every individual what people
really mean when they're asking the boy
or girl question is creepily so what
Genesis do you have people need to
realize it doesn't matter what living
meat skeleton you've been born in it's
what you feel that defines you
non-binary is a blanket term for anyone
who identifies out with the binary
gender there are endless ways of being
on binary and no two people identify in
the same way so just remember gender is
what you feel not what your parts are
don't be afraid to be yourself bye guys
oh wow I mean you know your feelings can
totally change based on your parenting
style I mean if you have abuse or
anything else that can really determine
what you feel so that changes who you
are and what you feel happens only after
you know the coding of your DNA which is
set in process a long time before what
you're going to think or feel so not
sure how all that works yeah well I saw
a lot of contradictions even in some of
the things that she said she said that
that you're according to what's in your
head not what your parts are and then
she refers to your biology as your meat
skeleton which it's interesting that
higher intelligence basically meets that
I deny the the DNA which is fixed and
it's something that's concrete that you
can actually use as an identifier but
the Bible is very plain in Jeremiah 17:9
it says that the mind is deceitful above
all things and desperately wicked who
can know it so I'm not saying that it's
wicked to not connect with your biology
but how is it that that enlightened
thinking is that I'm according to my
thoughts rather than what my body is and
so all that does is that just increases
this disconnect from the physical and
that you can be whatever you want to be
and that you could be a you know a Ford
truck if that's what you think inside of
mine yeah I think therefore I am okay
isn't it ironic that people think
Christians are nuts because they believe
in fairy tales like creation and God and
all this but oh it doesn't matter what I
am physically what I believe in my mind
that's what I really am like you're
living in a fairy tale Wow I never
thought of it that way that's really
interesting but I want to point out also
that the transgender issue we're not
talking about somebody that's
hermaphrodite or somebody with ambiguous
genitalia we're talking about somebody
who is completely male feeling like
they're not a male or somebody that's
completely biologically female and I
think that really the the new attitude
is that basically you can be anything
that you want to be in that we're we're
much higher or better or different than
what our biology is and you know it's
it's really sad to see that not only is
the media promoting this but especially
with young people they not only know all
these terms but they also accept this as
truth through them
so one of the things that I also want to
talk about is some of the issues that
are already coming into the church one
of the issues that we had is a mother
who was concerned that her that her son
who became her daughter was lost and
basically she had paid for her son to
have a sex-change and I think that it
warrants pointing out that just because
somebody is transgender does not mean
that they're gay there are plenty of
people that are transgendered that were
heterosexual even before their sex
change just as much as there were people
that were homosexual so you don't want
to make the assumption that somebody was
gay and transgender there are two
separate things what I'm sexually
attracted to is different than how I
view myself do you see the disconnect so
this is actually a man who had a
five-year-old son who called him daddy
and he had a sex change became a female
so now the mother called us concerned
that that his salvation was in jeopardy
because now that he was attracted to
females and now he's a female he's still
attracted to females so she's thinking
that now that her new daughter is a
lesbian that her salvation is in
jeopardy so when I thought about this
and I thought to myself you know what
you didn't change your DNA there was
nothing wrong with his attractions the
issue was in how he saw himself and so I
said to the mother I said the issue
isn't in his attractions his DNA is
still male and he can mutilate the body
he can change the body to make it appear
as female but the bottom line is is God
gave him the DNA of a male and so his
attractions was never the the issue that
was a problem so that I thought was
really amazing there was also a woman
who worked in a prison she had a
relationship with one of the prison
guards and after the third time that
they'd had a sexual relationship this
man confessed to her that he was
actually a she so now she's confused
she's sexually connected we know that
that did to become one flesh according
to you know first Corinthians 6 verse 16
that don't you know when you have sex
with a prostitute that the two become
one flesh so here she's connected to her
emotionally and physically and then
she's thinking to herself she goes wait
a minute I thought it was a guy but now
it's a girl and I have feelings for this
person am I
so imagine the confusion that was coming
inside this woman's mind as well I mean
that work a woman how does a prison
guard have sex with a woman and he was a
she I mean there's a sex change that
good that it operates and everything
yeah well I mean there's a whole lot of
details about the situation we're not
privy to but let's just suffice it to
say that it was after the third time
that this woman had sex with this person
that she did not know that it was not a
male so I don't know yeah yeah and I
mean it's just a crazy world that we are
experiencing right now where it's like
sometimes you cannot tell I mean some of
the pictures that we were looking at of
transgender people I mean for all
intense purposes they are the sex that
they're portraying I mean you would have
no idea I wonder though if the root the
root problem in all of this is we are
trying to define who we are instead of
letting God define who we are which is
really the more important situation okay
and I was listening to something the
other day I think it was about the story
of Balaam and Balak and the children of
Israel and and you know Balaam was asked
to curse the curse these people and of
course they they had been involved in
the you know some things in their past
that weren't so good but as as he's I
think he was commenting on them he said
that the Lord seen them as righteous and
it's really interesting to think that
the God has seen them as righteous when
you know when he looks at the way he
looks at them or looks at us God sees us
in a different way than the way we view
ourselves and what is more important at
the end of the day how we view ourselves
or how God views us if we view ourselves
in our in our own thinking you know
we're not going to be as valuable as the
way that God sees us
what's the connector what's the path to
connect it to how we
Oh God use this I'm not really sure I
mean I guess we have to align our
thinking with his thinking and I think
it come altum Utley what it is through a
relationship with Jesus that you
understand what heaven gave up for us I
mean literally God was willing to cease
to exist so that you have an opportunity
I mean that's that's that's infinitely
valuable the king of the universe would
trade places for you to be there I think
that that concept when you really
grasped that it changes how you how you
view you know your value yeah and not
just how valuable I am but but who I am
you know God God's the one that defines
who we are and if we don't find our
definition in God then you know our
definition can be whatever so that's a
really good segue because what I want to
eventually talk about is when did
sexuality become my identity and it's
interesting because less than a hundred
years ago nobody had a problem with
identity there there were two identities
in the Word of God and it was either
your identity was in Christ in Christ
I'm a new creature the old things have
passed away behold everything becomes
new or your identity was in self and so
that was the enemy and his his desire
for us to worship ourselves right in
Romans chapter 1 is that man worshipped
the creation rather than the Creator so
in the Bible we only had those two
identities where was it that all of a
sudden my attractions become my identity
well we have to look to a man called
Alfred Kinsey who was paid by the United
States to do all of this research about
sexuality and in his research he was not
only homosexual he was a a pedophile and
also a masochist and so Alfred Kinsey
died of his own sexual practice that's
how he passed away but this man was
given the funding by the United States
government to do all kind of research
and he skewed his research to basically
support his own personal gain as a
matter of fact Alfred Kinsey zidle was
Aleister Crowley who was considered the
most wicked man in the
back in England but anyway the point
being is that Alfred Kinsey was given
the funding and what he did is he
basically skewed his research to
basically support and he came up with
the statistic that 1 in 10 men were
actually gay but the research that he
was doing was actually in prisons and in
in jails rather than the populace as a
matter of fact he would actually pay men
to molest their daughters and would give
them a stopwatch to record some of the
some of the behaviors that they were
doing as a matter of fact in one of his
researches he determined that a
six-month-old baby girl had a total of
22 orgasms within a 24-hour period of
time and he used oral and digital
stimulus to stimulate this baby and his
definition of an orgasm was screaming
vomiting and passing out and this is
what the United States and the world now
is using as their as their research and
understanding to shape the education
that we're doing in sex education now
that's why it's coming into kindergarten
because Alfred Kinsey said that even
children are sexual but we also know
that by development a child that's been
exposed to sexual things become sexual
but for me myself I was never molested
and so sexuality and sexual thoughts
didn't even come into my mind until I
was 13 years old it seems like you would
have to deny scripture in order to go
down that path and what I mean by that
in Genesis it's it's clear it says God
made them male and female and God wasn't
talking about what they thought in their
head he was talking about the whole
person their physical makeup as well as
their mental makeup and so he only gave
those two options so to go outside of
those parameters it seems like you would
have to deny scripture and say no God is
wrong there are more than that not only
do we have to deny scripture we also
have to deny science I'm going to show
you that the transgender hopes is really
something that's that's being promoted
not only by the media but also by a
political government because even the
transgender understanding goes against
science and and even scientists that
have talked about the damage of what the
transgender surgeries do and the
statistics they support and show us that
the Bible's definition of identity is
still holding anyway what I want to do
is I want to take you to the cost of
natural and being a hairdresser for over
28 years it's interesting because
working with women I know the cost of
what it means to be natural and I want
to break this down a little bit as a
matter fact this is Bruce Jenner who
became Caitlyn Jenner through
transgender surgery but I remember being
a kid I remember being a young teenager
when he won the the Olympics and this
was considered the best athlete in the
world for his time male athlete and I
remember him being on the cover of my
Wheaties box and I'd be eating my cereal
thinking to myself wow if I could just
be as masculine as Bruce Jenner and so
ironically I can be I could be more
masculine than him now but the point
being is that he was struggling with
with transgender ideation he struggled
with it as a little boy and I really
identify with that and as he was being
interviewed he was talking about the
same thing that you saw before is that
the mind wasn't matching the body I
totally relate and I think that we need
to have extreme compassion for anybody
that's in this dilemma but what does it
mean to be natural and such a
contradiction because when I start to
break down what it takes for him to even
look this this feminine is he actually
had to have surgery on his nose to make
it more feminine he also had lip
enhancement he had to have his Adam's
apple shade and his forehead to become
shaved down to make it more feminine he
was going thin on top here and he was
balding so he had to have expensive
extensions put in hair transplants of
course highlights and and other hair
extensions because his hair but probably
naturally doesn't grow that long then
when you start to look at his body had
to have electrolysis on his entire body
to get rid of all of his masculine body
hair and then of course he had breast
implants put in because even the
hormones wouldn't grow natural breasts
for him and then a year or so ago he
actually had what we call the bottom
surgery where they take the male anatomy
and they mutilate it to a pure female
now there's a whole lot of issues that
can happen even with that a lot of
surgeries that aren't completed and even
when you're taking an external organ and
you're creating an internal organ
there's a lot of yeast infections
there's a lot of at
that goes on where the the organ
actually has to continually be stretched
so that it can actually become a sexual
instrument there's a lot of issues that
go on with that so for Bruce to become
Caitlyn to finally be his natural self
there's very little that's natural about
who he is today and so it's interesting
we buy into this ideology that what you
are in your mind you have to create that
physically but physically there's
nothing natural about it and I'm gonna
use this to also show you the extreme
because I believe that we have to show
as Christians we have to not only show
that God's Word is truth and I believe
that it also complements with science
but we have to show that it's actually
better than what the world is handing
out now when I was caught up in all of
the the the identity issues that I was
struggling with my desire was that wow
if I could look like that I would be
convincing and I would be acceptable as
I am and so I understand the desire I
also understand the drive but what was
so amazing is that twenty years old when
I came out of the gay culture
I remember cross-dressing at Halloween
thinking this is my big moment and it
wasn't like a game for me I was serious
work I remember my sister did my makeup
I wore wig I wore the dress the whole
thing but I remember that night as I was
celebrating the fact that finally I can
actually be out in public and and be who
I thought I was inside the reality came
to me is that wait a minute I still have
to shave tomorrow morning I have a chest
full of hair and and this dress was only
fitting because I was cinching in the
areas to make me look more feminine
there was nothing feminine about me and
it was a harsh reality that this is not
who I am and so what I found in gay
culture was that masculinity was more
valuable than femininity so if I butch
it up and worked out in the gym that I
really what I was after as I wanted love
and affection for men and that got
sexualized at puberty it also got
twisted around to think that well I'm
inadequate as a male and so I'll never
get affection that way because I wasn't
getting affection that way and so I must
become female so that I get that
affection
interestingly enough they now have laws
in their several states now that it's
against the law to counsel the child is
younger than 18 that they can actually
have heterosexual attractions or that
they can actually identify with their
biology but did you know that there are
many people and over 50% of of young
people that if just left on their own by
the time they're in their mid-20s they
eventually find heterosexual attraction
they find a connection between their
biology and psychologically and so they
don't have a problem but it's
interesting now that the law will refuse
to allow you to to guide a person into
that identity but you can only guide
them into transgender and homosexual
behavior and an identity so this is
what's going on in the world today and
being promoted and pushed by the media a
point you said it reminds me of the
videos that we were watching and just
hearing people's stories how to make
that kind of change it's not a one-time
thing for the rest of your life it's all
about maintenance it's a constant
reminder of who you biologically are and
to continue with trying to make yourself
or trying to go with how you feel is a
lifetime of maintenance and misery and
upkeep I mean the key that they have to
do just to just to basically continue to
feel that they're going in that
direction and we were watching this one
video of this one girl who had turned
into a male had taken the male hormones
for 15 years and she said that there was
a fog over her mind that literally was
like a depressing fog because she was
constantly taking these hormones that
were unnatural to her body and then she
was like I'm sick and tired of this I
mean I'm over it and I'm not gonna take
it anymore and she said it was like a
month a fog just lifted she had clear
thoughts all of a sudden her skin was
clear her her hair was clear and for I
mean she looked like a male I mean it
was interesting it's really sad because
what you said is that all the
maintenance to remind yourself of who
you are really I want to change that
statement a little bit it's a constant
reminder of who you aren't right that
maintenance because you have to
constantly maintain the hormones and you
know the behaviors and you know they're
physically there
skaars that go with that and I I think
that people really underestimate the
mutilating surgeries of what this does
let me give you a case in point there
was a young boy that was seven years old
in England single mother right and he
announced to his mom that he was a girl
and she not knowing what else to do sent
her son to a counselor they said your
son is transgender they started the
hormone blockers to the puberty
process he started to develop breasts
his voice didn't lower and didn't change
but all of a sudden when he was 13 years
old he announced to his mother he goes I
am NOT a girl I'm a boy but now he had
natural breasts because of the hormones
and his voice didn't change so now he
had to have surgery to remove the
natural breasts that the hormones
produce and also now he's got this voice
that isn't naturally or lowering all
because again we allowed a
seven-year-old to determine who they
were I mean I remembered my favorite
color would change on a dime you know my
favorite color might be red and the next
day be yellow how can we even trust that
a young child that isn't even mature has
the ability to determine you know what
sex they are it's it's interesting
because there are other decisions in
society that we say you are not old
enough to make that decision until you
are older for example there are smoking
and alcohol and gambling all these
things you have to be older to make that
decision because society wants you to be
quote unquote old enough and responsible
and mature enough to engage in those
activities but what this is the exact
opposite it's like it's almost like
people are being ushered in as younger
as possible to make a lifelong decision
that they don't even understand
necessarily the ramifications of at 7
years old you know I have a a six year
old and I assure you he does not see 10
years down the line 5 years down the
line he might he might think that next
year he's old enough to ride a ride on a
roller coaster because he's a little bit
taller but that's that's about as far
sighted as we're getting you know but
you know when we talked about the other
day the topic of abortion and that you
know I couldn't even go to a
movie that was radar but exactly we have
an abortion without the parents consent
you can't even rationally make that
decision that would impact a massive
part of your life yet yeah you can't see
the movie that tells me the power of the
media yeah they're trying to change
society you have to start with the
youngest change their whole mentality so
when it comes with body modification you
can't even get a tattoo it's how you're
18 years old yeah yeah you can't get a
mark on your body but you can do all
this stuff yeah you can change your sex
but it makes me wonder if if all of
those things like dominoes will change
as well because once you change
something as big as this and you allow
that large of a decision to be made for
the permanency of a life why not then be
able to get into a to you whenever you
want why not be able to drink whenever
you want smoke whenever you want gamble
whenever you want no matter how young
you are if that's what you want to do
right then it stands to reason you
should be able to do it take you back
into the sexual realm so okay let's say
if you're seven years old you can
determine your sex you can also
determine who you want to have sex with
drop the the age for consensual sex and
now pedophilia is legal though doesn't
know what they're pushing for you though
uh-huh so let me show you a thousand
percent increase in the transgender
issue in England alone all because of
what the media is promoting that I think
should be shocking but people don't talk
about the the fact that there is a lot
of people that are dissatisfied when
they had these mutilating surgeries and
what I find amazing is this woman who
was named Nancy who became Nathan was
actually allowed to have a lethal
injection a lethal assisted suicide
because she was not satisfied with the
results of her surgery it says as
reported in the Belgian news Nathan said
after surgery I was ready to celebrate
my new birth but when I looked in the
mirror I was disgusted with myself and
so the media isn't going to allow you to
hear stories like this at the
people that are dissatisfied with the
surgeries that they've had is there a
documentary that's made about this
person I know that I found some stuff on
YouTube are there statistics that have
chronicled this over the last sort of
nine to ten years or whatever yeah okay
as a matter fact there was a research
done on that was actually in supportive
of the transgender studies and they
found that a 41% of transgenders whether
they were before during or after the
transition found that 41% attempted
suicide
30% of transgenders will actually commit
suicide those are the highest rates of
suicide among any group of people and
when you look at the statistics that
alone lets you know that that the
transgender surgeries are not doing what
they're intended to do you know as a
Christian when we hear these kind of
numbers I mean here is a group that
needs to be reached these are these
people are literally dying on the
battlefield because they are feeling
unwanted and they've made a mistake
that's gone too far I mean these this is
a group we I think as a Christian
society need to focus on how do we reach
them with with the love of God
yeah I've come across similar statistics
in that particular demographic
transgender in the realm of cocaine
usage smoking as well as alcohol abuse
and what it made me wonder is is there
something going on in their lives that's
driving them to these substances like
why then as a population versus
heterosexual male or female why are they
seeing higher rates of abuse of those
substances versus people who are not
transgender is there some kind of
psychological thing happening is it
rejection of society is a depression
what is going on that makes them go to
those substances now the media wants to
promote that it's actually bullying that
drives someone to become a drug addict
or or to be wanting to attempt suicide
but really when you look at some of
these countries that have have LGBT
marriage and rights for many years 20 30
years when we look at Norway when we
look at Belgium they've had those laws
for many years and yet the rates of
suicide are still the same they're
unchanged and the rates of alcohol and
drug addiction is still
saying the term that we used when I
worked in a psych unit is that the drug
abuse is basically self medicating it's
trying to resolve some of the conflicts
that are going on and I believe that
what happens is with the transgender
issue it doesn't solve the problem it
just complicates the problem so matter
of fact odd this is a research that was
done by dr. Paul McHugh and he works at
John Hopkins he's a psychiatrist
he says support of transgenderism and
sex change surgery is collaborating with
madness and they did an exhaustive
research and they found that the
transgender surgeries does not give the
people ultimately what they want and
this is actually the link to the article
if you're interested yeah I really think
that when somebody is not seeing
themselves as who they really are in any
other situation you try to seek counsel
I I'm ugly I'm fat you know there's just
I agree with what he's saying like to to
put you know if somebody says I want to
die
that's like saying really well I can
help that I can help you do that I mean
that's the same logic so there's a term
called body dysmorphia and what that
basically means is that I'm a healthy
human being and I have this left arm but
you know something in my mind that I
will not be whole until I can remove
this left arm and so body dysmorphia
means that that I feel detached from
this arm and that it should be gone
nothing wrong with the arm it works
perfectly fine there are doctors that
are willing to remove my arm so that I
will mentally be whole and they actually
make a connection between the
transgender issue as well as body
dysmorphia but isn't that illegal to to
remove a healthy opinion as a doctor
who's willing to do it yeah school I
have a question yeah so I'm really
wondering if it's more than
transgenderism if there's some
underlying issue or some power control
seeking well I say that is because I'll
just give some examples this take South
Africa which is 90% black people and 10%
white but when you remember apartheid
where the white population pretty much
overtook the entire black population why
is that
that the majority would have the rule
but know that 10% was able to break
apart that 90 and cause division and
that's how they they ruled and you look
at the United States where it's really
the top 1% that's controlling everything
and then you look at the transgenders in
America is less than 1% yet all these
laws are being made all these changes
are being made all these conversations
are being had for this group of people
and instead of kind of helping we're
more enabling and it just makes me
wonder if there's more to it than just
people wanting to be different than who
they were biologically we are so I yeah
I mean this is this is a whole different
topic but I really think that there is
some crazy technological advances that
are coming down the pipeline and those
technological advances they are aiming
at trying to have a whole new human race
so they're messing with genetics they're
tinkering with in the scientific world
and they have basically said by 2049
they're gonna have a whole nother race
that's not human it's more than human
and in order for you to accept that you
have to break down what it means to be
human and tear that apart so I think
there's a lot that's going on here that
the elite and other people are pushing
these ideals and I mean they're in
control the media right so what's what's
happening in Hollywood what's happening
in all this and it's being promoted
heavily but I think there's a lot behind
that that will we'll uncover at some
point but complicated just a little bit
more because now there's a contradiction
going on with the LG B and the T part
because basically what's happening now
is if if I'm non-binary and I don't
identify as male or female then you have
no homosexuals and you have no lesbians
or bisexual you're just non-binary so
even that's a contradiction to the LGB
and so there's there's now even
discussion among the group that where
they they want the t to be separated
from the LGB people
LGB part because again what that does is
it destroys even their understanding
that I'm not a male attracted to males
I'm just a non-binary attracted to
another person or individual it's almost
like if they had an agenda it got
hijacked by another one exactly exactly
right I don't know if you've ever
connected this do you think any of this
could have to do with like what's in
food water I mean talking about your
eating things are pumped full of
hormones could that have any effect on
us and if that was a case you would
probably see a lot higher incidence
because I don't think it's happened
you're basically all going to the you
know same basic grocery stores which are
outsourcing their materials from us I
make those difference basic places yeah
yeah but you got and food doesn't have a
food has a part in genetics it can turn
genes on and off so do you see a lot of
trans vegans I mean that's kind of an
interesting thing yeah I so I think that
if your mind is fogged with all kinds of
things does food actually really
impacted that would that would be an
interesting study and a lot of times
those are questions that we get in our
presentations is what does diet and and
your water and your surroundings does
that have an effect and so okay let's
give us the benefit of but now let's
just let's just say that that has an
influence right so it does God still not
have the power to redeem individuals and
what I find so beautiful and I want to
really Segway a little bit now you know
after this next slide I want to segue
into you know what is it that God thinks
about the whole transgender issue and
what if I saw an amazing is that I find
great compassion when when you look at
the verses about where it talks about
how woman should not wear the clothing
of another woman nor man for it is an
abomination when I really unpacked that
first God's not calling the transgender
person an abomination he's calling the
behavior an abomination because every
time my aunt would take me into the
bathroom and tease my hair like a girl
what it did is it gave me this great
fascination that I could now be
identified as the opposite sex something
that wasn't gifted to me by God but God
doesn't condemn the person that that
doesn't relate to their physical body
because he understands are there reasons
why but what I find so beautiful about
God is he said the abomination is in
that practice because what it does is it
pulls you further away from the blessing
of the biology that I gave you I find
that incredibly compassionate on God's
side as a matter of fact with the with
the gay issue as well he does not
condemn the homosexual because he
understands that there are reasons why
you have same-sex attraction he said but
don't do the practice because what that
does again is it destroys the ability to
relate as a man because that's how God
made me to be I find great compassion in
that and again I want to eventually show
that for the person that's transgender
or for the person that has a relative or
a loved one that might be LGB or T is
that we want to make sure that this is a
loving and compassionate approach to
dealing with this issue and to try to
provide the answer that God already has
given to each one of us we're not here
to judge them or to bash them I
certainly wouldn't because of my own
history but I think again that God's got
something better in in store and I say
118 is beautiful so it's come and let us
reason together and basically what we
want to do is just unpack what science
is talking about and using that to
affirm what God's design is for us
people are really looking for a
transformation of their biology or body
like I'm telling you God wants to
transform our minds you know I mean it's
it should be an easy thing for people to
understand you know if they've you
believe that you can transform your
biology God can transform our mind so
the Bible also addresses that it says if
man looks at the outside but God judges
the heart and what we're talking about
is a heart transformation the heart and
the mind together I like Keith how you
were talking about how we're a
combination of the physical and the
mental but Allen ye and biology even
science psychologists record recognize
the fact that we're like three strands
in a rope and those three strands are
physical in the spiritual and mental and
that basically the psychologist says
that you can't do anything sexual
without bringing in all of the other
aspects so meaning that I couldn't even
give myself away sexually and think that
it was just a physical interaction that
there was a spirit and also a mental
aspect to that as well and so if the
devil knows that and that he can destroy
God's people by stepping outside of the
confines of what God said
healthy sexual behavior was then what
we're doing is we're destroying not only
the ability to relate to God in a loving
way but we're also destroying the very
image of God because that was the
blessing that was the culmination of the
man coming together with the woman in a
committed relationship that was the
fullest expression of the image of God
remember in Genesis so again ultimately
the desire for the enemy is to destroy
the separateness of the male and the
female and that combination together
because if you can't tell who the
husband or the wife is then you destroy
the image of God again so I want to
segue a little bit into some more of the
science this is a website that you can
go to the science and myths and facts of
the trans movement this is a gentleman
he's actually on the board of the
pediatric Association and what he does
is through this video he breaks down not
only the media movement but also the
political movement - basically - and and
abuse the the science that has already
been established through the transgender
issue and how they're promoting an
agenda and he even acknowledges that
it's a it's a powerful powerful
documentary to watch and to find out
exactly what's moving the transgender
movement and also the lies that are
based behind it so I want to share now
this is a gentleman that we actually
interviewed on pure choices his name is
Walt higher wild higher started off as a
little boy and his grandmother wanted a
girl and so every weekend he would go to
his grandmother's house and she would
make these beautiful dresses and she
would dress him up and and affirm to him
that he was her beautiful little
granddaughter well when he was about
seven years old he brought one of the
dresses home and exposed their little
secret but already he got the message in
his mind from his grandmother that he
would he only had value as a little girl
this became also affirm when he was 13
years old and he started being molested
by his uncle now Walt never struggled
with with homosexual behavior or
attraction he was still heterosexual but
by the time he was in his 40s he
realized that he was transgender he had
a full and complete sex change he had
multiple surgeries to make himself
appear female even the bottom surgery
but as he was living this he said you
know at first he said it was like this
this he said it was like this honeymoon
period
and he said he felt fulfilled he was
happy he lost his wife his family lost
his job he was basically homeless and he
started to realize it you know I've had
all these surgeries but it still didn't
make me female I still wasn't having a
monthly cycle I wasn't able to to
conceive a child and I realized that the
DNA again that was coursing through my
veins was male and that everything that
he done was a fraud at his lowest point
alcoholic suicidal living in the streets
somebody introduced him to Jesus Christ
and that changed his life and he
realized well if I could have a sex
change to become a woman what if I could
have a sex change back to become a man
and so this is who walled higher is
today and he's got an amazing amazing a
website called sex change regret dot-com
and he talks about not only a lot of the
statistics that I've shared but also he
talks about interviews with other people
that have also been dissatisfied with
their sex changes as well what's amazing
is that there is no female brain in the
wrong male body current studies do not
support the transsexual condition nor
did the current studies support the
Harry Benjamin syndrome and there Harry
Benjamin syndrome was something that was
developed by Alfred Kinsey and his
associates as well okay any dialogue on
that I mean if you if you want to
understand something about the sex laws
that Kinsey Report is it's a hard video
to watch but if there is a lot of
information in there that basically give
you a context of the twisted Mis that
that has come to where we are today as
planned
yeah but it's just it's just you can see
how it's really gotten to this level
here and yeah it makes sense why now
we're having such a confusion in this
area I mean this has been this has been
something that's been brewing under the
surface it's all calculated and it was
intentional and it started about 70
years ago it seems like it would be you
know really beneficial for people to see
both sides if you haven't been through
that you don't know what's coming
down the road right and so to look at
somebody else's experience seems like it
would be really helpful it's like you
know there are people who have gone
through for example an abortion you know
and is it an expecting mother you may be
grappling with should I have an abortion
or not it seems like it would be helpful
to talk to somebody who's had one and to
talk to you know people who haven't had
one and find out is this the right
decision for me to make instead of just
taking the Nestea plunge so to speak and
doing it without any thought of what are
the ramifications of this long-term you
know it is it always going to be that
honeymoon phase or there gonna be second
thoughts sure so I want to move now into
the biology of sexuality and isn't it
interesting to note that mothers produce
a different biological recipe for sons
than they do for daughter and so I want
to segue now into God's blessing and his
design for sexuality and what I find
amazing is that not only does God design
a different formula for the for the
breast milk for males and then females
but there's something even deeper and I
want to basically share with you what I
think is the grandest part of the
presentation is is the story of Ray to
Marissa and so this is actually a female
who was transgender she was raised in a
home where they didn't talk about God
and so her parents didn't care you want
to wear Spiderman underwear that's fine
she cut off her hair as a young girl she
would fantasize about her wedding day
but instead of being the bride she
wanted to be the groom so by the time
she was 16 years old she was living it
as the male in a relationship with
another woman as a lesbian and she
decided that she hadn't had the sex
change she would hear the voice of Ray
inside her mind that would say say you
know what you shouldn't have those
breasts and you shouldn't have soft skin
you need muscles and you need facial
hair and so what she did is she moved to
Seattle Washington where she knew that
she could have a sex change she was
living in the community and so she went
to her therapist and the therapist was a
transgender male-to-female and basically
looked at a tray at that moment and just
said you know if I could I'd approve you
for the surgery right away but you have
to live it as a male for another year
and a half and so but she did approved
for her to have the hormones you can see
that some of the pictures here there's
facial hair and that Ray was moving in
that direction
but the voice array just became louder
inside her head and just said you know
what you're so pathetic nobody will ever
want you you should just kill yourself
so again living in this fog not knowing
what else to do she couldn't even get
out of bed to go to her therapy
appointments she called the only person
that she thought would actually listen
to her it was a person that she hadn't
spoken to him many years and and that
person knew her as Marissa but she
called it for the first time she left
her her old name Marissa on the
answering machine and she said listen
I'm in a bad way I need some help and a
friend called her now if anyone would
have called her Marissa before that she
had gotten angry she would have clenched
her fists and she would have looked at
him and she said don't call me that
anymore my name's not Marissa it's ray
but her friend called her and and said
listen just come to me just come to me
and she wasn't going to judge her about
her life or anything else and tell her
that she was you know crazy and
depressed because of how she was living
she she cared more about the fact that
she just wanted her friend to live and
her friend said you know I don't have
any money to buy a ticket she said I'll
pay for your ticket so ray flew out to
her friend in Colorado and a friend just
left her and she said you know what I'll
call you Ray I'll call you whatever you
want I just want you to live and so she
didn't stand on principles or or or
ceremonies with with her friend but she
was praying for her while her friend was
in bed and couldn't get out of bed so
what's interesting is that the power of
God that's still alive today
started to have an inroad on ray and so
ray thought to herself one day during
that three months and she was with her
friend she thought to herself she goes
you know God how do you see me first
time she ever prayed and what she saw in
her mind when she saw this woman in a
dress just praising the Lord with long
flowing hair and she immediately
dismissed that said That's not me but
during that time as she was healing as
she was starting to read the Word of God
all of a sudden she came to Psalms 139
and Psalms 139 if I could just really
just sit on that for a second is really
the answer from God to the transgender
issue because the first part of Psalms
139 talks about the pursuit of God it
talks about how you know I can go up
higher I can go down low I can go into
the darkness but God is still there
because the darkness is the same as
light it goes on to say that his
thoughts towards us are as countless as
the sands of the seashore so the first
part of Psalms 139 talks about the
pursuit of God the love of God his
desire to be with his creation
but then it segways and says I knit your
delicate inward parts together in your
mother's womb and for Ray that was an
obvious passage from God that I was
intentional about the femininity that I
gave to you and so right then at that
point she started to embrace this and
and and the Lord spoke to her and said
you know what you've been living as a
man for all these years have you ever
thought of trying on femininity and you
know it wasn't like a light switch on
the wall that she could just flip and
say okay I'm a female there was a
process to it but what she could do is
she could start letting her hair grow
out and as she started to let her hair
go out she started to replace some other
clothing with more feminine clothing
what's so amazing is at the same time
she's growing in the Lord she's
accepting what he says about her and
even in Jeremiah says that before the
earth was formed I knew you and I knew
you to be a female and what happened is
she started blocking the voice of Ray
inside her head and the voice of Ray was
really the enemy because God would never
tell you to take your own life and as
she started to embrace her femininity
this is who Ray is today as Marissa
and I really like to point out the fact
that this took nothing this didn't cost
millions of dollars for this
transformation and again people judge
the outside but God judges the heart and
what you're seeing here is a
transformation of what God did inside of
the heart this didn't take expensive
surgeries and that God was able to do
this through the as you said scottie
through the renewing of her mind and you
can see the joy on her face you can you
know she's she is who she's supposed to
be and you can see the contentment in
that face yeah yeah what I think is even
even more gives more glory to God is the
fact that because she didn't have those
surgeries because in time she she didn't
submit to the knife and have those those
mutilating surgeries as she was walking
in the Lord eventually she got married
to a man changed her not only your
attraction but she married this guy and
what's so incredible is she actually had
a baby a year and a half ago and she's
pregnant now with her second baby what I
find is so amazing is again like I said
that that God's Way is not just the
truth it's got to be better than what
the world is heading out now if she
would have had those surgeries she would
have been living without the hormones
she would have had to be on male
hormones for the rest of her life that
increased her rates of cancer and also
decreased her longevity she never would
have had the ability to actually hold a
created being in her arms and to look
into the face of that child or to nurse
that child because she would have had
her breasts removed so again what's so
powerful I think about Marissa story is
it shows that God's Way is not just
truth that it's better than what the
world is handing out and and in my
closing the the comment that really
comes to my mind is that we get thrown
into this bunch where where we're
talking about behavior modification like
you know people say oh you know
Christians you know you're trying to
make gay people straight or you're
trying to make transgenders you know
behave differently that's not our job
our job is not to make gay people
straight or to make transgender people
happy with their biology our job is to
let people be in touch with Jesus Christ
to begin a relationship with him and to
let his transforming power make the
difference because we're not talking
about behavior modification we're not
talking about a divine transformation
and I think that if the Christian Church
gives up on on recognizing the power of
Jesus Christ is still alive today that
we are watering down the gospel we're
not offering to people the divine
restoration that God can provide you
know it seems like people are willing to
go to great lengths to try anything I
mean very random things surgeries
cutting things off you know what if you
were to just literally say okay God I'm
gonna give you a chance I'm gonna give
you a chance to let me live the life
that you chose for me because like it
like in Jeremiah I mean knitting you
together in the womb really if you say I
am born in the wrong body that's really
an attack on God you chose the wrong
person you are the one that put me in
this body and you chose wrongly and it's
an attack on God but what if you could
actually just say you know what I've
tried everything else to try to make me
happy
I'm God I'm gonna give you a chance and
I'll give you a window go for it and I
guarantee you you will not be unhappy
so what you said reminds me of Malachi
where it says prove me now herewith if I
will not open the windows and pour you
out a blessing that you cannot receive
it and so thank you for that Scottie
because for the person that is out there
that is convinced that they're in the
wrong body or for that person out there
that has confirmed that that
homosexuality is their identity then
hold God accountable and that would be
my my statement to them is that put him
to the test he made it very plain he
said not only come and let us reason
together but put me to the test and see
if I will not give you something if and
a lead better than what you're
experiencing today I love that challenge
I think that that's that's perfect to
share with those people that may not
necessarily even agree with what we're
saying right
awesome what a great story to end on
yeah I mean it's an amazing cuz that's a
heavy topic to kind of like even wrap
your mind around and I appreciate your
your you know coming and giving us from
your personal experience because you
know it is when worlds that I have not
lived I have not experienced I do not
have someone close to me that has
struggled in that mindset and so to hear
you you know your personal experience
and to give us a little bit of knowledge
from that that's why we want to started
this conversation in the first place I
know there's a lot of people out here
that are truly searching and and like
Mike said you know give God the
opportunity to to show up and be the god
that he he's promised to give you a
peace that passes all understanding and
hold him to that promise because that is
truly what people are searching for
right peace and happiness and if you let
God have that opportunity I guarantee
you will not be sorry I think it's
important you know in this particular
episode were singling out one particular
phase of life but really this applies to
multiple phases multiple issues that
people are dealing with you know for one
person it's transgender for another
person it's alcohol and gambling or
cigarettes for another person it's
pornography addiction but whatever it is
God has an answer for it that's right
and he can deliver any person from
anything that's the power of the gospel
Michael thank you for coming hmm are you
kidding thank you awesome is awesome all
right so I hope you guys enjoyed the
show click like subscribe check out some
of our other videos and keep coming back
I love you and god bless you and if you
guys have any comments we want to hear
about them we want to interact with you
guys so if you have questions comments
definitely let us know if we can point
you into the direction of some of the
research that we've come up with this
we'd be more than happy so god bless
[Music]
you